[Musique]
bien avant cornwell invente une invasion
d'extraterrestres aux états unis vient
journal que lancé l'idée qu'ils avaient
une invasion d'animaux à new york
[Musique]
nous sommes le 9 novembre 1874
les gens se réveillent à new york y
prennent leur journal et qu'est ce
qu'ils trouvent des nouvelles assez et
peur hante
on apprend dans le journal que de
terrible calamité les animaux sauvages
et carnivores du zoo de central park qui
sont en plein coeur de la ville de new
york se sont évadés au total 49 victimes
hommes femmes et enfin le journal donne
des détails assez cru on raconte qu'un
rhinocéros a foncé vers un groupe de
jeunes filles et on a tué beaucoup qu'un
lion et intime qui se seraient battus à
mort et que lille ou aurait mangé les
serres
plus fort encore on retrouve dans le
journal une proclamation du mr le maire
de new york donc qui exhortent la
population à rester chez elle parce que
justement les animaux carnivores et
sauvage risque de les tuer
à la fin de cet article on peut dire ça
y est c'est la catastrophe mais faut
toujours tout lire
pourquoi parce qu'à la fin de l'article
est écrit que yo rien de vrai dans tout
ce qu'on vient de lire
bref c'est un canular pur et dur
pourquoi est ce que le rôle d' au fait
sa belle à raison pratique c'est de
faire de l'argent quand il ya du
scandale ça fait vendre et il y en a
beaucoup qui vont dire que c'est pour ça
qu'on a inventé cette nouvelle là mais
au journal on va avoir une version un
peu différente on va dire non non non
non non c'est pas pour ça
simplement on veut dire aux gens que
c'est un danger potentiel que le zoo de
central park et que cette catastrophe
pourrait arriver
donc en gros c'est pour aider les
autorités à se prémunir contre une
éventuelle catastrophe
ouais c'est ça celle-là on la croit pas